okay i get a challenge from a 2100 let's
play them
hb pencil one all right let's play
hb pencil one 2094. that's a good rating
okay so let's play a french i've been
getting some requests to play a french
i'm going to do that and um
in the french there's two main lines you
can play the winner but should be four
attacking the knight on c3 which is
defending the pawn
but the move that i prefer to play the
move that i actually have played is just
knight to f6 attacking the pawn
now white has several moves here yeah so
bishop g5 is one of them
now you take on e4 that's the main line
and basically you get this very
interesting structure
where okay bishop b7 developing the
bishops cutting into the pin
uh the main move here is bishop takes f6
basically it's this
principle here is the same gtx f6 as in
the modern where
we give white better control of the
center but
in return we get several things this
pawn structure is very easy to
misunderstand
it looks bad but remember what i always
say when we have several pawns masked
together in the center that can actually
be a good thing
we have that f5 in our pocket but we
don't want to play f5 yet
um we want to find a good place for this
bishop
i'll explain everything after the game
we could take with the bishop that's
also possible where should this bishop
go
and definitely not to d7 that just seems
really awkward
yeah we should definitely fianchetto the
bishop this is a perfect place to do it
then at some point we're going to go f5
our bottom line idea here with black
is to put pressure on the d-pawn we can
actually do that by castling long where
we probably will castle on
because castling short here it's not
that it's unthinkable it's actually
possible in certain positions but
uh when we can't guess along we
definitely should okay
yeah f5 would weaken e5 we should
definitely factor that into our
calculus here now
so what what kind of moves can we play
here what should we do
how should we go about playing this
so there's a move that we can make that
is not a developing move per se
yeah so knight c6 is possible but we
have to be very careful about
essential strike like d5 now the first
thing we're gonna do here nobody has
suggested this move yet
look at the g file for a second um i am
a big fan of developing flexibly so
not revealing entirely what i want to do
yet and a way of doing that would be
rook ga let's
actually make sure that white castles
and if white castles
then it's i would say easier for us to
develop
in a way that would be more conducive to
attacking on the king side if white goes
g3
well then he weakens the long diagonal
and then i'm going to show you guys
the best way of developing here it's
going to blow people's mind
but there is actually a logic to it the
best move the best way that i've learned
to develop my pieces here
is actually to play c6 i'm going to play
this move now and i'm going to explain
it after the game but
basically the idea is this if you were
to go knight d7
what would you allow what move would be
very nasty in that position
yeah i know c6 looks terrible but if we
go knight d7
we allow him to break through with d5
that is not pleasant at all
so c6 temporarily stops him from going
d5
now we can go knight d7 and we've opened
up a little window for the queen on c7
now i know what you guys are thinking
aren't we blocking the bishop like
isn't that doesn't that violate the most
basic rule it does
but this is a this is a dynamic factor
because at the end of the day we are
probably going to play c5 and unlock
that bishop once again
this is a temporary measure that we're
taking to prevent d5 until we are ready
to reopen the board with c5 there's
nothing so in other words
the bishop has a lot of potential energy
now he's attacking the pawn what would
be a good way to defend against that
pawn and i've mentioned this move before
yeah the move is f5 notice that the
knight on d7 also guards the e5 square
so he can't put a knight there
we can also improve the position of our
dark squared bishop by putting
it on the long diagonal and basically
fulfilling our ultimate goal
which is to attack decor let's actually
do that bishop a6 here is possible
but it's not that scary and against
bishop a6 we have a really interesting
idea
now let's take a look at this knight for
a second very carefully
if we go c5 here he can still go d5
this knight on d7 is sort of stumbling
in our way
and there is a way that we can improve
that knight it's a particular type of
maneuver
it's not like b8 the knight would be
super passive well the knight is bad
because it's sort of blocking the rook
the move is actually b5 and
we pave the way for the knight to come
to b6
and potentially we can push the pawn
with b4 and that could be very
unpleasant
now aren't we weakening our king well we
are but
as i've said many times what you need to
understand here is that white isn't
doesn't have the firepower
necessary to really exploit this
weakness look at how many pieces are
next to our king
it's really not a problem um it's it's
not something that you should be worried
about
uh when you when you understand how many
pieces there are next to the king and
the fact that white really can attack
okay that he just made a big mistake
he missed a particular move what did he
miss
the opening was a french
so rook g4 is creative but let's take a
look at this knight for a second
this knight actually has no squares so
we can trap the knight with before this
literally just traps the knight
and when i played b5 the way that i saw
this is i sort of noticed that b4 was a
general possibility
and so that means you have to test it at
least for a couple seconds on every move
this wins the knight
that is a nice little french french game
here
and uh yeah he's busted here he is
busted 94. we take it he's given up
tonight for what he can
now he's attacking this pawn let's go h5
independent we also create a stronghold
for the rook on g4
we can involve the rook that way and the
rook will be able to attack the d4 pawn
although that's not necessarily
mandatory we can also just double the
rooks which i kind of prefer
i kind of prefer the idea of doubling
the rooks playing more centrally
and the rook from d5 okay so what do we
do here that was a mistake
we need to be very attentive to how the
position has changed
so he's getting his knight to b3 we need
to stop him from doing that
and if we are attentive well rook g4 is
not necessary we can just straight away
take
i think he's watching my stream he just
said rook takes d4
no you're definitely not stupid for
struggling to get 800 that is
far from easy okay and and we're we just
trade rooks
actually if we want to be fancy here oh
we have a sexy winning move here
now what am i noticing here i've said
many times what is the worst defender of
any other piece the queen
the queen is the worst defender of any
other piece
queen is defending the rook queens are
very easy to distract
and we distract the queen by going queen
e5 if he takes the queen
and we first take the rook with check he
covers it with his knight and then we
take his queen if he doesn't we are also
threatening checkpoint he's busted
immediately
if he gives us a distraction a
distraction check on 85 we can just move
the king actually
um so that was a nice game
so that was um kind of complex this is
why i don't recommend the french to
to certain players i feel like you know
i feel like there's a lot of structural
new structural things that you have to
understand about it in order to play it
effectively and
that's just not always easy to do on on
demand
now knight c3 is the main line
knight f6 is the steiner's variation of
the classical variation
bishop b4 is the win hour which is the
more most popular move
um this is fine like this is a decent
move this is the main move
but the way i learned it is with knight
f6
now e5 is the main move along with
bishop g5 and basically
this creates a pawn chain the idea of
going knight f6 is that the knight is on
c3 it's blocking
the move c3 which means that c5 is going
to be particularly strong undermining
the base of the pawn chain
and the main line continues f4
protecting it from the other side
and basically the battle much like in
the advanced french revolves around
whether we're going to be able to get to
that pawn on d4 this should make sense
to me to you guys
hey good game man thanks for being the
stream that was that was great
so he plays bishop g5 how do you deal
with queen g4 i'm not sure in which
position
well if they push g5 right away that's
called the advanced french
um that is what i have played with white
and c5 c3 knight c6 it's like the same
type of position
our moves are going to be geared toward
trying to get rid of that d4 pawn to
make white's pawn chain collapse
that's really all there is to it there's
a lot of theory there
okay now f6 would be a thematic mistake
these moves are possible on the french
but we're attacking the tip of the pawn
chain and normally
as we know we want to attack the base of
the punch and that's just like the main
thing you want to
you want to do okay um i hope that makes
sense
all right looks like it does make sense
i don't want to bog ourselves down too
much with the opening theory so it takes
takes bishop b7
bishop takes f6 now why didn't i take
bishop takes outside so like the reason
this is a move but gtx f6 has a lot of
these
hidden benefits like we get the g file
open for ourselves
and we can potentially play f5 and pave
the way for the bishop to come to f6 if
we play bishop takes f6
then he can first of all take the bishop
and really simplify the position we
don't necessarily want that
we actually keep the two bishop
advantage by taking the pawn so
there are these complicating factors and
the fact that the pawn structure is kind
of weak
is yes that's a detriment to this but
it's not the only disadvantage
so knight f3 b6 right bishop d7 is super
passive
and it allows this very very nasty pawn
breakthrough
so we want to prevent that bishop b7
rock g8
forcing him to weaken his position or
reveal the fact that he castles
i think rook g1 is inaccurate i do think
white should castle
i think white should castle um even
though
later on i mean we can use the fact that
i'm pressuring g2 i do think that's the
best this is absolutely i've played this
over the board
this is the main line i think in
classical games bishop e2 is considered
inaccurate
um there's other ways of playing this
for example g3 here is a good move
and the idea is to deploy the bishop to
the long diagonal if black does the same
what does white have in this position
yeah if he takes for the knight then we
take him to the bishop
i'm sorry i had to get a bite of
chocolate that's the thing
and um there's a lot of theory here so
rook g8 rook 21c6 now this is the key
move
i want people to so somebody asked can't
white play d5 anyone will know he can't
because we just take it
we've got two defenders on the pawn and
two attackers which means he cannot take
yeah we can play bishop a6 but the
bishop is actually a good
piece we don't actually want to trade it
even though we can
so rook g and rook g1c6 now i explained
the logic during the game but just to
recap
we fact one we need to develop tonight
that should not be a surprise to anybody
we need to develop the knight we need to
complete our development
we also have to castle at some point we
can't keep our king in the center
forever he's ultimately going to go
d5 and we have two three ways of
developing the knight and all three of
them allow d5
knight c6 allows d5 because it obstructs
the bishop
and i wanted to make sense to everybody
why allowing d5 is nasty
the reason allowing t5 is nasty is
because we have
a deficient pawn structure which means
our king is weaker
which means we don't want to let him
open up the center just yet until at
least at least until we castle
so knight c6 allows d5 knight d7 also
allows d5 because
it obstructs the queen and uh
you know in contrast to the other
position
we can't take white's queen this is very
very bad for us
um so that's as i explained what makes
it so good for white because the fact of
the matter is
our pawn structure near our king is
worse than whites
so when he opens up the center he
exploits
and he sort of magnifies the problems
created in our pawn structure that's why
we want to keep the center closed
yes you can go e5 but now white's carved
out some weak squares y can go here and
then here
we've created a very big weakness on the
f5 score we've also blunted the bishop
white can also go here right and put a
bishop on f5
creates outposts for his pieces we don't
really want to do that
a c6 you guys will see is a very
thematic move
in the french in these positions i can
show you many games where this move has
been played
um queen queen d2 97 the other benefit
of c6 is that we find nice ways to
develop our knight and queen thank you
zinc right we go queen c7 our queen
isn't in the way
king b1 castle and now we're basically
ready to play c5 uh we don't actually
have to rush with this move
uh and we didn't in the game but um
we are ready to play this should the
occasion present itself so c5 here would
be already
something we could think about because
here i would notice
that the rook x-rays the queen which
means we could move the knight out of
the way
the pawn would be in trouble i'm not
saying this is like the best thing we
could do
black could continue to prepare c5 black
can also do b5 and knight b6 and that
also is the idea we applied in the game
also very typical so that would also be
a possibility
well e5 here would not open the bishop
so he could ignore this and also
i remind you that this creates a
weakness on the f5 square
which is not the end of the world but we
don't necessarily just want to
create weaknesses for free thank you
kryptonite 64 for the prime
okay so i've studied these positions so
i kind of know these ideas so f5
f5 would be perfectly good bishop f6
improving the bishop
here for example c5 would allow d5 again
and we can't take because the bishop
hangs and also he's moved the queen away
from
away from the pin away from the x-ray of
the rook so
bishop a6 is fine now we go b5 thank you
b
go 97 appreciate the prime and um
the idea behind b5 is to improve the
positioning of our knight and to begin
the attack against this king
why is the knight bad on d7 because it
blocks the rook
and because on b6 it can potentially
jump to c4 which is a really really nice
square
so g3 knight b6 and now the decisive
mistake blundering the knight
what should white have done here several
possible moves maybe rook d3
um and then vacate the d1 square not
ideal but
at least this doesn't lose the knight
you could also go a3 but that would
create a hook
and that would create a hook which we
could exploit by going a5 b4
that would not be my favorite move i
think white is slightly worse here i i
don't like white's position particularly
but uh you could also go queen e3 and
open up the e2 square for the night
although knight c4 now is possible so
you guys can see how unpleasant things
have become here
um i think that white made a series of
inaccuracies uh that led to
a nasty position so
that would be my my suggestion g3 knight
b6
rookie one b4 winning the knight h5
depending upon doubling rooks just
taking the pawn
and now the simple queen e5 wins the
game because we're threatening checkmate
we're threatening the queen and if he
takes
rook takes d1 as an intermediate move we
take the queen we're up or we're going
to work on a knight
so you know that's why these structures
are unique
it's not impossible to understand the
motivations behind a move like this
but it's hard to find this if you've
never seen this move before it's very
unintuitive
to to close down your bishop like this
uh
with the fore knowledge that ultimately
you're going to open it back up again
the other thing and i've made this point
many times but at this higher level
it's okay to have one of your pieces be
passive for a certain period of time
um because black has such a solid
central pawn structure
you don't actually need this bishop to
be super active yet that's not a
necessity
a white's pieces aren't that active
either like white's bishop isn't that
active like dirk is passive then i don't
c3 isn't doing much
so it's okay even for 10 15 moves
for your bishop on b7 to be not the
strongest piece in the world that comes
back to a point i've always made
so that not every one of your pieces has
to be curing covet or distributing the
vaccine at any given moment
it's okay for a piece to be doing
something
like working inside of the machine you
know getting the
the machinery to run from inside of an
office building rather than from
you know a place where everybody can
tell that it's good if that makes sense
well c6 let's see if the computer likes
it
yeah so c6 is not necessarily the best
according to the computer but i think
it's quite decent um
i actually think if we let the computer
think here it'll it'll appreciate c6
and um yeah it's very complex like at
this level you need to find ideas like
these
to make stuff work uh but the logic
isn't
unrealistic i've explained every step of
the logic
but it's just hard to get yourself to
play this that's just the reality of
chess at like a 2300 level
um your pieces are cramped you're not
attacking anything directly but that's
temporary
that is entirely temporary um eventually
once i open stuff
up his position is going to collapse
really fast it's one of those lines
where you do stuff for a long time
you're not attacking anything but then
when the position actually opens up you
know you make everything up you you
all of a sudden your pieces become
really active hey gary
um the computer actually at a very low
depth it says knight c6 i'm not sure why
it's not worried about this
oh it's saying knight before okay this
was interesting actually
couldn't white have exploited the fact
that i'm undeveloped well white is not
developed either
white is not developed either uh so it's
not like
if i had a queen here and white had a
rook here yeah that would be different
but
uh i'm i'm developing very fast to
castle queenside so white just doesn't
have the
the power to exploit that if that makes
sense this is also theory
like it's theory and i i know that and
so i know that this is legitimate
right even if i did a rook on g7 it
would not be easy to
to do anything it's very hard to give
checkmate in general
let's play dm 85 and let's go d4
um so it's time for us to branch out a
little bit i'm going to play the java
london which i play at my own level
and i'm going to give you guys a little
run through as to the main ideas of this
opening
i i know that
whoa gary 500 inc thanks gary
okay now basically we're just developing
pieces now we go e3 we support the d4
pawn we do not take on c5 and i'll
explain why after the game
and this is already a mistake this is
already a very big mistake that is one
of the appeals of playing the jibaba you
guys can see that good players
fall into this trap knight b5 and
there's no good defense
against knight c7 there is no good
defense
against knight c7 short of moving the
king out
which is probably the best move honestly
but pretty disastrous
on its own and um e5 here intercepts the
bishop but it drops upon i've shown this
line before
and um i would caution people that is
the reason i haven't played this before
i would caution people
to do this stuff solely for the sake of
getting your opponent to fall into traps
and he actually plays this the best way
he actually plays this the best way now
a6 attacks our knight counter attacks
are made
now the reason that we don't want to
play e takes f6 if we calculate here ef6
a b5
and then if we if we play bishop b5 we
fall into queen a5
check which wins the bishop now knight
d6 check he would take on d6
and then the pawn on d6 that would
result would be weak
so what is the simplest move here we
don't have to overthink it
just play it simple the pawn on d5 is
weak
so if we operate from that perspective
we can just go knight back to c3
just go knight back to c3 we're now
attacking his knight
if he moves his knight he drops the d5
pawn he's gonna be two pawns down
although it's not as simple as that um
because we need to watch our own
position d4
okay now um let me think about do we
want to play ed
first no we don't let's just take take
his queen
now what would be the simplest move here
and
we don't want to rush we need to develop
a tempo
very very typical way yeah developing
with tempo
castle long check and now we are going
to be up a full healthy pawn in the end
game let's take here
now the reason we didn't play fg is
because that would help him develop
right we don't want to help our opponent
develop his pieces
now we have a simple end game we are
upon up but we need to be very precise
this is not going to be easy to win
um especially against a very strong
opponent like dm 85
now how should we go about developing
here who can propose
a a move here now basically like what we
need to realize here we need to do a
couple of things we need to figure out
okay where does our opponent want to put
his pieces and this bishop on c8
he wants to get it to e6 and target the
a2 pawn so let's start with a move
bishop c4 but if he goes bishop e6
there's a five head move that we can
play he probably is going to go bishop
e6 now we don't want to take his bishop
we don't want to take his bishop because
that would help him correct his pawn
structure
if we play bishop b3 we got our bishop
trapped but we can go bishop d5
and if he attacks the bishop we can
support it by pushing these one of one
of these pawns
he takes on d5 we get our rook to a
really really nice central location
so bishop b3 is the right idea but the
wrong execution the rook g8
no problem so he's attacking the spawn
we can we can just defend it
we can go g3 it's an awkward looking
move but remember that he can't attack
this bishop so the fact that this bishop
is sort of trapped is not a bad thing um
there's no way to attack it
and um in fact the bishop is now very
well protected there's something that
looks wrong with this move but there
actually isn't anything as far as i know
um rook t8 so we can play c4 or we can
play e4
uh both moves have a case that can be
made for them
um i do like c4 the the potential
issue was actually no i do like c4
actually i do i do like c4
well there actually is an issue with c4
and i did miss a move here
but that's okay i think we have a
response to that move
uh the problem with this move is i did
not actually practice what i preach i
didn't understand
which squares this move leaves behind
let's see if equal b5 i thought about
but but it drops the knight
that that i did think about we should
have got e4 though e4 was better
and yeah he find knight before so he
attacks the bishop now let's prioritize
here if we move the bishop
if we move the bishop then he plays
knight takes a2 check
disattaching the king from the rook so
it's a lot more important to preserve
the bishop than to defend this pawn
which means
we should go e4 we should go e4 it's
yes we give up the pawn but that's okay
because we still have a monster bishop
he's playing extremely well now we
should develop our knight and connect
our rook so we don't have to worry about
the stuff anymore
now we potentially are threatening to
take on b7 although
f5 would be a super super strong move
here let's see if he finds it oh but
then we can maybe still take on b7
f5 we can actually take on v7 and that
gets a little complicated
but his king is weaker than ours so i
think that should pay off in the end
yeah that was an inaccuracy by me but
you know i make these mistakes all the
time
it's okay um i should have done e4 first
and the pawn on c3 would
have guarded before that's why it's so
important at this level
to when you whenever you move a pawn you
allocate
three four seconds three four five
seconds to understanding
okay what squares am i leaving behind
can he occupy those squares
flyer 10 hello now we need a plan
we need a plan there is a very typical
plan in such positions right we have a
file on which most of
the action is happening that's the d
file so logically speaking what can we
do
to emphasize our control over the file
and knight c3 is good as well we can
improve the knight
but let's double rooks double the rooks
that should be a plan that's not
surprising to anyone
that is the classic way of exploiting
our control over a file
here's how you should okay so 95 should
we take the knight
should we take the knight
and don't say no just because i'm yeah
we should
i got you guys i know a lot of people
will say no because on
on like tests and stuff yeah why not we
take the night look at how
lame his bishop is just staring at all
these pawns look how lame his bishop is
now we get to double we win a tempo
guess what that's as good as it gets
ladies and gentlemen that's as good as
it gets
and um goes bishop e7
i baited you guys now we can play
several different types of moves
uh this knight on on e2 let's improve
the knight let's get the knight to a
civilized square
potentially we can get it to d5 but
let's not rush because if we take the
bishop on e6
why is it well this should be seven he's
got rook b8 winning
winning the the the bishop so let's
prepare
bishop takes b7 actually let's let's go
h4 first let's expand a little bit on
the king side
let's deprive the bishop of the g5
square and we are preparing a particular
move here
yeah we want to move the king i want to
move it to c1 but if i moved it to c1
immediately
he would have this check that would send
me right back so we go
h4 to take away the g5 square from the
bishop
in preparation for kingston now a lot of
you might be asking well why the hell
didn't we just move the king to the a
file well it wasn't that easy
i didn't want to move the king to the
eightfold because it's an endgame and in
end games
you know it's not a great idea to move
the king away from the center
and i want to keep the king relevant
that's basically the bottom line now
we're kind of threatening bishop takes
b7 although it really depends on what he
does
yeah we want to make sure our king is
active in fact we can bring the king all
the way to e3 that might be a good idea
if he does find a way to defend the pawn
yeah there's a lot going on here i'm not
explaining everything but um i think you
guys are getting the gist of what i'm
doing
white is better here it's a very hard
position to play okay so bishop g4
i know what all of you guys are thinking
we should play f3 but this is actually a
really clever move if we go f3
he drops his bishop back to c8 and guess
what happens the pawn on g3
becomes extremely weak and his rook
attacks and then if we go g4
he wins the pawn on h4 so let's just
move our rook up let's not
let's not make any reactionary moves
these are moves that a lot of people
struggle with a move like rook t2
is not an intuitive move right when we
can block it with tempo but
you got to learn how to make these kinds
of moves
um yeah so he goes bishop c8 anyway he
defends the pun
now we need to scour the position for
other weaknesses okay what else can we
attack here
what else can we attack here we can we
can go 94 and attack this one absolutely
let's tickle him
he's low on time so it's a good idea to
create more threats
and if he plays b6 okay so he moves the
rook away okay
does he create any threats no where can
this knight potentially go
where can the snipe potentially where do
we want this knight how do we prepare
remember the rooks have done their job
so we go rook b3 to prepare to sink that
knight into p6 what does that accomplish
well that gets the bish ooh and there
comes the panic okay that we applied a
lot of pressure applied pressure there
comes the blunder
now we give a check and now what do we
do now that the bishop has gone from e7
what do we do who can tell me the move
we actually just take the pawn yeah well
it's not that it's a meltdown he was
under tremendous
pressure for most of the game now um
we can just shift the rook back to b7
and pressure the bishop
if the bishop moves away then we take f7
so we take f7 where three puns up
we take g6 and here we have an
intermediate move who can tell me the
intermediate move
well we go here i have to move now what
we want to do here is we want to get the
rook out of b7 so we give a check
now we give another check we take the
rook we move away from the check
we can go here and we win the game okay
because if his king moves and we take
the bishop so
if we took the bishop immediately i'm
trying to be accurate until the end we
give up
that was a really nice game and it was
very well played by dm thank you thank
you for the game
let's unpack what happened here now this
is the jabal london
uh the reason it's called that is as
i've explained before
it has sort of roots from
well badur jabba george and gm uh really
popularized this in the last couple of
years
uh this this has been around for a very
long time it was first played in 1882 by
james mason who was one of the strongest
players in
he was irish actually but he was
definitely top 20 in the world in the
19th century so
james mason actually played this in 1882
alekhine was the fourth person to play
this alekhine played it twice that's how
good these people were
um and then it really was only played a
handful of times until the 80s then in
the 80s
people started playing it in the 90s
people played it and then
really in the last 10 years badorja baba
really started playing it regularly i
picked it up about five years ago
i thought it was a good way to avoid
theory it's very venomous opening
very venomous now the reason that it is
frowned upon
what is the reason that the move knight
c3 is frowned upon in general this is
called the varisov
the traditional varasav is to put the
bishop on g5 but why is this like
not considered to be mainstream
yeah because it blocks the c pawn and as
you guys know in the queen's pawn
openings
the move c4 is like very commonplace
that's the main line
so when you block the c pawn you have no
way of contesting black's control over
the center
but i think it's better than the varys
up now essentially part of the idea of
playing the jaba is that white actually
can play oftentimes on the king's side
and ideas like playing g4 are very
common here so bishop f5
f3 is one of the main lines and white
literally wants to play g4 and h4
jabba himself often pops into the stream
so like
g4 and h4 is oftentimes a very very
typical idea i've played like this
and white basically plays this like a
karo khan like white just attacks the
king side
very modern chess right people wouldn't
do this 100 years ago because this looks
outrageous how could you move your pawns
here what are you doing
well white can castle the other side and
why can't even keep his king in the
center i can even park the king on f2
which is a surprisingly safe square and
um
to show you guys like a good example of
of how i applied this stuff
i'll run through very quickly one of my
games in the java where i applied this
idea
and i'll show you why it's not that easy
for black to
uh to really exploit the weakness of the
king it's it's you know this doesn't
tell the whole story so here's a good
game of mine
now seductive orange looks like i
guilted enough people
we do we do have to get to 5700 we're
two away
that we have to do so basically
as you guys can see here's f3 g4 and h4
um that is what i just showed you guys
and what happens is
i don't actually cancel [ __ ] hurts
gifting to the raven try thank you
but basically yeah there we go king f2
and lamelac with the tier one thank you
now here's the here's the the rub here
the king may look very weak but it's
actually very hard to get to it
it is true that i have pushed out my
pawns to g4 and h4 but that doesn't mean
the king is easy to attack that's hard
for me to sort of explain
at a granular level but i hope this
makes sense and what happens in this
game
is that i actually checkmate him on the
queen side i get my pieces to the open g
file
and i just attack him my king remains
very safe the entire game
rook c8 penetrating king takes g3 it
eventually moves to g3 thank you
five minutes dead and the game ends when
i just basically just checkmate him
knight takes d5 ends the game because if
he takes then queen takes e8
and the king actually participates as an
attacker rook after king g4 would win
win the king it's queen is also hanging
so
that was a nice game that's a you know
there's more to analyze here i've played
the juba many many times
whoa holy smokes phineas gage75 gifted
to the community
my man amazing thank you phineas
for gifting to friendly mayhem light
opsb
clayton sororex and paul r hanson ctrl
gets that 3am hype going love it thank
you for the five gifted sir
yeah it'll be hard to play for it'll be
hard to play for
for for lower rated people because it
involves like not because i'm trying to
condescend to anybody it just involves
knowing when to violate these principles
right things like king safety you don't
want to play you don't want to mess
around with that's playing with fire
um so the juba is a very dangerous
opening to play
um i always compare this and have since
the start of the speed run like
think of driving a bus right you haven't
learned how to drive a car and you sit
down
behind a bus and now you're trying to
navigate the city streets
right you need to master the mechanics
fully before you attempt something
relatively crazy and
even i crash that bus sometimes i've
lost some painful games of jaba
okay now let's go back to the game
basically he goes
c5 which is one of the main lines and
knight c6 is a very typical mistake
so a6 here either before or after c
takes d4 e takes d4 is the main line
a6 stops knight b5 and in this position
you can go either knight c6
or you can go bishop g4 immediately pin
the knight and increase the pressure on
the d4 pawn this is one of the main
lines of the juba
black has a fine position here it's you
know
there's a lot of theory here i've played
several games in this line
knight c6 is a mistake in ip5 and now
look at what happens he cannot stop
knight c7 literally
king to d7 here is very bad because of
bishop c7
and a position like this is just
absolute disaster look at his king
95 check is coming a 95 check is coming
that's going to be absolutely
devastating so
yeah this is horrible uh a6 is not
wasting time a6 stops knight b5 and
potentially prepares b5 so you got to do
what you got to do in chess
okay so e5 d takes e5 a6 and now
um if 94 i've showed this before what is
white's best move here
and um what what follow-up tactic does
white have here good good
job by my opponent not missing this
often times people tilt into missing
this
yeah queen d5 queen e5 knight c7
and you pick off the queen your two
pawns up the king is lost it's castling
right
black is completely lost so that's a
nice little follow-up
a6 knight c3 and now d4 very good move
because now if he moves to the knight we
can just take on d5 with the knight
the d4 takes takes takes king d8
castling with check and now b takes c3
and the thing is
f takes g7 bishop g7 helps him develop
his bishop
you want to be careful about not moving
your opponent's pieces for him
right by by doing this we both ruin our
pawn structure respectively but that's
okay
because i'm the one who's up a pawn this
is not going to be easy to win though at
all
why did he take your queen with his king
instead of his knight that's a good
question i
i think he should have probably taken
with the knight i think because it's an
end game that would probably not have
substantively changed
the evaluation because now he has to
waste a tempo
improving the position of his knight um
and
that in effect is similar to him moving
his king in fact
the end result of this will be exactly
the same if he plays knight c6
that literally transposes to the
position from the game
that literally transposes to the
position from the game okay
so bishop c4 stopping him from get going
bishop e6
um he goes bishop e6 anyway and now
bishop d5 one of the key moves in this
game
so bishop takes c6 would be bad although
it would trade pieces which is good
what's bad about this is it corrects his
pawn structure and there's no need to do
that unprovoked
bishop b3 is the typical move in such
positions but it allows them to trap the
bishop so concretely it just doesn't
work
and that's why we played bishop d5
centralizing the bishop now we go g3 to
defend the pawn
trade on your own terms and now c4 is
the inaccuracy that i mentioned
e4 was better because his knight is
totally limited by the pawn my good
friend robert hess
he talks about this all the time when
the pawn is
three squares away or depending on how
you look at it two squares let's say
in between the pawn and the knight and
they're on the same file the pawn often
restricts the knight you guys you guys
can see
that the pawn on c3 bad as it appears is
actually completely restricting the
knight
from either jumping into the center and
jumping onto the queen side i actually
didn't
fully appreciate that and pushing the
pawn to c4 opens up
the possibility for knight b4 not a good
move
but we did damage control successfully
here e4 supporting the bishop
okay he wins the pawn back white is
still better i've got this huge outpost
if he ever takes then the piece is
replaced by an equally strong
pawn and his knight gets in trouble
doesn't have any waist back
so knight c6 rook t3 doubling the rooks
taking on e5
why did we want to trade knight because
there's no reason not to
right there's absolutely no reason not
to
um i think uh master c i think that
exists on my youtube channel if you go
into playlists i think that actually
does exist my editor has been working
very hard to ensure that that happens
so you should check it out if not i will
make sure that that is done
but i'm pretty sure that that actually
already exists
one second because the knight is active
and the knight is the actual tool
that he can use uh to attack the c4 pawn
like the c4 pawn is
weak by taking on e5 we remove the load
on that pawn the other thing is you
could easily have a situation
where you have a very bad bishop for a
good knight so bishop takes d5 we could
choose between taking with the pawn
which
a case could be made for that's a pass
pawn but i would def definitely take
with a knight here look at how monstrous
this knight is look at how bad this
bishop is
staring at a bunch of its pawns of its
own color that's the other reason we
want to trade thank you nathan or as for
the prime
take that horsey off the board h4
hopefully the logic behind this move
makes sense to remind you guys we want
to go king c1
why do we want to go king c1 because we
do want to take this pawn
but we cannot take it because he pins
the bishop and wins it so we need to
move the king
we can move it to the a file but then we
would draw it further away from the
center we don't want that and we want to
go king c1 for it to be closer to the
center we can't do that because of
bishop g5 check
that sends the king right back where it
came from so h4
covers the g5 square now we go king c1
bishop g4 rook d2 right not playing f3
just
got to be in general careful when you
push pawns particularly in the end game
because you create weaknesses no need to
create that weakness we go rook d2
bishop c8 knight a4 pressuring the pawn
on c5
now we go rook b3 preparing potentially
the moon knight v6 now we're not
threatening knight b6 immediately
because he's got two rooks covering that
but we're accumulating the pressure and
we're also by the way attacking the pawn
which i don't see a good way
for him to defend if he went b6
um defending the pawn who could propose
a plan
what would we do in this position like
what specifically
would be a good plan here for white and
this is actually not easy to play
yeah nice so one good plan would be to
bring the king to e1
and what this does is it takes away
the task of defending the f pawn from
the rook
which means that now we can bring the
world to the default guess what we are
attacking b6
now we're attacking v6 now it is true he
can defend a bishop d8 but i want to
show like some of the key ideas now
maybe we decide okay the knight has done
its job let's bring the knight to c3
we can even play bishop a8 because that
bishop is pretty unassailable
and the bishop could be replaced with a
knife so in such positions
what you want to remember is to play
very slowly it's important not to rush
and you want to poke and prod poking and
prodding
is the key to winning these positions
you can't win it in one fell swoop
it's not easy but when you poke it
ultimately your opponent is very likely
to make a blunder just because that
that's how it is and that's what
happened here he went low on time
b5 yeah not the last flyerton thank you
heatley31
he blunders the pawn our rook gets in we
blunder we win the other pawn
rook b7 we win the third pawn and now
a simple intermediate move right if we
take here he takes here we're still
winning but no need to do that
we give a check and another check saving
the rook
and now we win the rook and now we win
the bishop and he lost on time but the
game is over
anyway so does that all make sense guys
does all everything i did here make
perfect sense
um we sort of we put the pressure on my
only real serious mistake i think was
was the move um was the move c4 i think
that that wasn't practicing what i
preached it opened up the b4 square but
we
prioritized correctly and we managed to
push him off the board eventually
[Music]
you